I'm sure that this story is not going to
come as a surprise to a lot of people in
our audience because you already
probably knew the likely truth but there
are some explosive new leaked emails
that seem to confirm that yes Donald
Trump personally ordered that aid to
Ukraine be frozen until such time that
smear investigations into Joe and Hunter
Biden were publicly announced by the
Ukrainians and it feels like this is
almost a story from years ago it is from
last year technically because it is so
obvious what we are now learning but
indeed the leaked emails are
communications between the Pentagon and
the White House is OMB Office of
Management and Budget and in the emails
a staffer for the OMB Mike Duffy emailed
the Pentagon and said quote clear
direction from POTUS to hold meaning
clear direction from the President of
the United States to hold the aid to
Ukraine this is one sentence which makes
it very clear that these are the
president's orders the orders are hold
the aid to Ukraine period now there are
many more emails the other emails don't
explicitly repeat that these are Trump's
orders but that's the context that's the
framing that's the obvious reality that
we have suspected for a very long time
this was Trump's call it was Trump's
call all along people were acting at the
direction of Donald Trump now there's
other emails that are interesting that
have leaked and were still going through
them and in another email involving a
Secretary of Defense Mark Esper's chief
of staff McCusker McCusker said in an
email when the Pentagon was ordered not
to release the aide McCusker said you
can't be serious I am speechless
so the lie that Donald Trump wasn't
doing this wasn't involved that it
wasn't deliberate those were all just
that they were lies let's address
another issue that's been sort of
wrapped up in this that's important to
get to at this point there's a wing of
the left that is starting to implicitly
or explicitly excuse Donald Trump's
behave
in this Ukraine Fiasco by saying we
shouldn't even be arming Ukraine right
so there's this this wing of the left
that's saying we are funding Ukraine's
military as a proxy war against Russia
and I don't like that okay this is this
is a lot of people on the left from this
slice of the left that are saying this
some of the people saying this are part
of the revolutionary left as we've
decided to non pejoratively refer to it
others are merely contrarians okay let
me see if I can be sort of clear here in
how I say this you can be against the
foreign policy decision to give Ukraine
money for weapons you can be against
what Ukraine is doing with the weapons I
don't care that's fine that's legitimate
political discussion it does not change
the corruption and bribery of the Trump
administration using the military aid as
a way to strong-arm Ukraine into
publicly announcing smear investigations
into John Hunter Biden for the benefit
of Donald Trump's 2020 reelection I'm
fine discussing whether we should be
arming Ukraine or Saudi Arabia or Israel
or any country that those are perfectly
reasonable political discussions but
much like I'm fine
discussing whether hunter Biden's board
position on the Ukrainian gas company is
appropriate those are not actually the
issues here and it is serving as a
really great way to enable Donald
Trump's behavior to implicitly defend
Donald Trump's behavior to help Donald
Trump avoid consequences to split the
left about impeachment we shouldn't
participate in that period so I I
respect the position I respect the
debate about who should the United
States provide military aid to who
should we be arming what about supposin
proxy wars that the United States has
waged for decades I mean look at Latin
America there's so many different
examples these are legitimate
discussions I have no interest in
shutting down those discussions but
where the slice of the left goes too far
is when they play directly into the
goals of
the trumpets which are too muddy the
waters and to make the issue of Trump's
corruption and bribery about something
else
to make it an adjudication of Ukraine
versus Russia to make it about Joe Biden
to make it about hunter Biden it's going
to get Trump reelected if it takes hold
and we don't want to do that now to go
back to the leek deal right I don't
think we do maybe there are some on the
Revolutionary Left who do want that who
are saying if it's not going to be
whoever they want they almost would
rather it be Trump part of this break it
all down to build it back up mentality I
don't subscribe to that I know that
there are some people who do let's get
back to the emails the White House knew
these emails were damaging to their
narrative and the White House blocked
these documents from being turned over
to the house for their impeachment
inquiry once again it's not hugely
surprising and this of course throws a
wrench into Mitch McConnell's plans
Mitch McConnell was hoping to keep these
documents out of the eventual Senate
impeachment trial now that they've
leaked now that we know that they exist
I don't know how you justify keeping
them out of the trial we'll see if
McConnell is able to come up with
something once again if we want this guy
held accountable we're going to have to
vote him out in ten months it is not
looking like there is going to be any
other path to holding him accountable
even being impeached we can't count on
the Senate we're going to have to vote
him out in November of twenty twenty
twenty and the fundraising around
November of 2020 is what I want to talk
about next
so you're someone who enjoys thinking
about politics you love learning about
countless other topics but you just
don't have enough time in your week to
read or listen to all the books you've
been meaning to get to blink astiz an
app that will completely transform the
way that you absorb information and
ideas because what they do is take
thousands of non-fiction books extract
the most important insights and
information and then present each book
to you as text or audio which you can
consume in just 15 minutes
imagine how well-rounded you will become
once you have the ability to read five
books in one sitting or listen to a new
book on your commute every day obviously
we should read the full versions of
books whenever we can it's what I try to
do but
is a reality that there's a whole world
of books out there that you will never
get to but blinka swill help you get to
more i just finished listening to catch
and kill by Ronan Farrow super
interesting book probably already
familiar to some in my audience and a
really interesting take at how Harvey
Weinstein and his alleged transgressions
were brought to light excellent
investigative piece you'll be able to
have conversations with people about
totally new topics you can feed your
curiosity in ways that you've never been
able to before and the best part is it's
only about eight bucks a month which
gives you unlimited access to every
single book in their catalog they have
books on politics economics philosophy
science you name it you can try it out
yourself totally free for a week and get
25% off if you decide to subscribe just
by going to blink is comm slash Pakman
I've put the link right underneath this
video